In your pseudocode, you may want to write a computation. Such as the total cost
equals purchase price, plus the cost of gas. You might want to have a decision.
If the total cost 1 is less than the total cost 2 to one thing, else to another
thing. You might want to repeat certain steps. While the bank balance is less
than your target, or repeat some actions say, ten times. Those are the three
essential elements of pseudocode. Computations or other actions without any
regard of the syntax of a particular programming language. When you're doing
programming there are two things that you need to learn, that's syntax of the
programming language and how to solve problems. And we'll do this in parallel
on two tracks. In the next lesson, you'll learn quite a bit more about how to
work with the programming language. But right now let's learn a little bit more
about algorithms, pseudocode, and problem solving. You've just seen an
algorithms that manipulated numbers to give you a useful answer. But I thought
it would be more fun to show here a few example that don't have to do with
numbers. So here is Robbie our home robot. A robot is a computer too, it
carries out tasks and one has to program it to do the right thing. Right now
Robbie's task is. To clean up a bunch of legos, Robbie needs to put all the
blue legos before all the yellow legos. Here's our first attempt at an
algorithm. It's a sequence of steps. Robbie will wave his magic wand and he
will say, make it so. Well, that's not really going to work. An algorithm has
to be executable. And not involve magic steps. Our pseudocode, here, asks
Robbie to repeatedly execute these statements. Namely, why all the blocks are
not yet in order. Each time, Robbie is supposed to scan the sequence of blocks.
Find the first one that's yellow before blue one, and swap. So Robbie would go
along starting at the left, until it finds the yellow one before blue one. Swap
the two. And then it would do it again. In the next step, it would scan from
the left until it finds the yellow one before blue one and swap them, and
again. Now I'd like you to try this. If I write a b for blue and a y for
yellow, tell me the sequence of the blocks after the next slot, and the next
one after that.